hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar health economic value
of tau project and testing a
gastroenterologist perspective I am Judy
Oracle bloggers and I'll do moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning brought to
you by nova diagnostics anova
diagnostics part of orphan has been a
trusted source for autoimmune disease
Diagnostics for over 25 years enova
diagnostics is redefining autoimmunity
by delivering solutions which anticipate
the needs of the autoimmune laboratory
they develop new biomarkers to enhance
patient care and help your laboratory
improve the efficiency and quality of
testing to learn more visit www and
nolvadex com let's get started you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them in
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Katie park and
the assistant professor of pediatrics
gastroenterology at the Lucille's salt
or pepper Children's Hospital at the
Stanford School of Medicine dr. Park
serves as the co-director of Stanford
children's IBD Center and the medical
director of the short State infusion
unit at Stanford children's health dr.
Park scientific investigation stems from
his formal training and health services
and Policy Research with background in
biostatistics study design database
analysis and decision science his
current NIH funded
search to discover cost-effective ways
to manage Crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis dr. Park will now begin his
presentation thank you Judy I appreciate
the introduction and thanks innova for
sponsoring me in this educational
didactic session as we had mentioned as
Judy I'd mentioned the title of my talk
is health economic value of calprotectin
testing a gastroenterologist perspective
so I'd like to go ahead and start by
providing a broad overview of the talk I
want to talk about the clinical
ambiguity that is exists between the
diagnosis that people are more common
with which is irritable bowel syndrome
acronyms IBS and folks might be aware of
inflammatory bowel disease which is IBD
and the complicated internal interplay
between symptoms and how that can
complicate how we approach the initial
diagnosis I want to talk about health
care utilization trends for both of
these particular entities I want to move
on to providing a little bit of
landscape in understanding what it means
to enhance the value of clinical GI
practice specifically as it relates to
the utility of calprotectin testing and
then I want to talk about where the
field of inflammatory bowel disease is
heading for non-invasive monitoring of
bowel inflammation all right so let's
talk about what this word value means we
have heard about this value based health
care and this is basically a good
schematic of how we should perhaps
provide some visualization of thinking
about quality high value health care
basically means
high-quality care that's evidence-based
that's intent on improving health
outcomes without decrease without
increasing costs so doing more with less
the idea of the two diseases that I am
always thinking about I BB and IBS it's
important to understand that there's a
lot of clinical overlay here and when I
see a patient with diarrhea abdominal
pain and possibly weight loss i can
actually in my mind think that this
patient has irritable bowel syndrome or
inflammatory bowel disease so there's a
lot of overlay between the two diagnosis
yet these two diagnoses are very
different inflammatory bowel disease is
a chronic inflammatory process that
causes visible all serves inside your
intestines and will not go away without
immune modulation or some therapy
targeting the inflammation irritable
bowel syndrome or IBS is a functional
bowel disorder when I mean functional is
that you can basically function with the
disease but it's not comfortable
patients have abdominal pain they may
have diarrhea they may have disordered
stooling or defecation and sometimes
they may even see mucus in the stool
suggestive of some inflammation but it's
not necessarily inflammation but rather
some malabsorption because of the mal
digestion that's going on within the
intestine so whenever I see a patient
with these classic symptoms I can think
of irritable bowel syndrome and
inflammatory bowel disease but what is
calprotectin calprotectin
has really catapulted onto my radar in
the last few years and it has changed my
practice calprotectin is a calcium bound
protein extruded from perturbed
inflammatory cells primarily intestinal
neutrophils within the walls of the
mucosa so essentially what that means is
it could potentially be increased with
with neutrophils that have died and
extruded their cytosolic contents into
the into the into the lumen of the
intestine calprotectin makes up sixty
percent of the sight of allah protein
within neutrophils and monocyte so what
I'm trying to get at is the fact that
whenever I have a patient in my clinic
there's clinical ambiguity between the
IBS and IBD and whenever I think about
inflammatory bowel disease I may even
have over-reliant or under reliance of
patient reported out and reported
symptoms so whenever i have over
reliance on patient reported symptoms i
may start to escalate medicines i may
start to increase health care
utilization and health care services
such as emergency room visits
hospitalizations even but whenever i
have under reliance of symptom reports
such as abdominal pain i can potentially
miss and i can potentially be misled in
thinking that that that a patient really
has something that needs supportive care
rather than immune modulation so it's a
delicate balance and there is great
clinical ambiguity at the point of care
so irritable bowel syndrome just to give
you perspective it's a very common
problem
would say up to a third of patients have
some recurrent abdominal pain in the US
but for patients who actually meet the
Rome 3 which is the diagnostic criteria
that you have to meet for a formal
diagnosis of irritable bowel syndrome
only about 15,000 per 100,000 but I want
to make sure we understand that it's an
entity it's a clinical entity that
requires a lot of healthcare utilization
is even acute care services such as
emergency room visits over 9.6 million
ED visits occur and that's probably
underestimated annually in the u.s.
about 1 million or more ed visits are
occurring in children less than 15 years
of age the costs are enormous and this
is actually just one type of irritable
bowel syndrome notice the sea enero
bowel syndrome type c and what that
means is constipation so this eleven
thousand dollars represents only one
type of irritable bowel syndrome so this
is in order of perhaps more for patients
with a diarrhea type which can
definitely be somewhat debilitating and
have low quality of life office visits
are forty percent of the total cost in
patient care and other therapies can
make up a substantial proportion of the
whole and ER visits is not dismissible
here either focusing our attention on
inflammatory bowel disease however the
prevalence is much less Crohn's disease
and ulcerative colitis make up 28 to 43
out of a hundred thousand but in
children and then possibly 200 to 250 or
so out of a hundred thousand and adults
and there is great economic burden
health economic burden for
for this particular disease chronic
disease and this is where my expertise
and research has been focused on and
when you think about the cost of care it
is actually even double or more than
irritable bowel syndrome it's up to
twenty thousand dollars per patient and
we'll talk about that in a research
article that we just published in
american journal of gastroenterology so
moving ahead on this is the paper that
we just published it's the american
journal of gastroenterology which is the
leading journal clinic reading clinical
journal in in my sub specialty and what
we did was look at eleven different
health care or health plans across the
united states so it's a representative
of all the subgroups of patients across
different geographical regions in the US
and we found that there is tremendous
health care utilization for inflammatory
bowel disease namely Crohn's disease we
we found that in across-the-board this
therapy called biological therapy has
been increasing in exponential trends
about eighteen to nineteen thousand
dollars will be expended annually for
Crohn's disease patients who are adults
and then even above twenty thousand
dollars per year for patients who are
less than 18 so it's actually more
costly for pediatric patients and young
adults but what I'm trying to get at
with this abstract slide here is the
fact that we live in the age of
biologics right there in the first
sentence
the age of biologics or the era of
biologics is upon inflammatory bowel
disease care we're talking about drugs
that are infused or given as an
injection these drugs are well known to
the public they're there on the
commercials and people are aware of
these drugs and they are very effective
yet very very expensive so here's the
pie chart that basically summarizes what
we found almost half of all I BB
therapeutic half of all costs are pretty
much expended on pharmacy related costs
and it is because of the biologicals
that we are using on that is so great at
treating and getting patients under
control with inflammatory bowel disease
and improving their quality of life yet
it actually is very expensive so
judicious use of these expensive
pharmaceuticals will be the hot topic
looking ahead in the age of in the era
of biologics so I wanted to step back a
little bit and as I was trying to come
up with this talk I thought about my
patient who really fit this talk well so
it's a real patient obviously I haven't
put any real identifiers into this
scenario clinical case but it's a 16
year old female adolescents who reported
several months of abdominal pain
diarrhea but no real weight loss she was
a high achiever she's a cheerleader very
smart and overall pretty
health-conscious without real medical
problems except for perhaps and seasonal
allergies she didn't have any sick
contacts there weren't any travel
meaning I wasn't thinking about you know
diseases that that occur when you go
abroad
there was no precipitating events there
were no precipitating events that led up
to her coming into my new patient slot
on her primary care pediatrician the
primary medical doctor PMD did a CVC the
complete blood count a complete
metabolic count a celiac panel and
infectious stool culture panel
everything was negative however there
was blood in the stool and we saw that
on the occult card blood testing in in
the office and we also tested for c diff
which if you've heard about Clostridium
difficile it's been in the news lately
it can wreak havoc on your GI tract
especially after a course of antibiotics
and that was also negative so the
patient basically I'm sorry um the
patient had a seed if that was positive
and we ended up treating that c diff
with oral metronidazol which is flagyl
and we ended up following up at a later
date and she comes back three months
later after the initial contact and
reported on going abdominal pain early
satiety occasional diarrhea and fatigue
and she actually looked worse however
repeat see this testing was negative and
the CBC was normal the complete
metabolic count was normal but a
slightly low albumin at a 3.2 and but
remember albumin which is a protein in
your blood can go down if you have
increased diarrhea or if you have
ongoing poor nutrition so that's what I
initially thought well I performed an
ethical gastro do with an Oscar B or an
EGD which is the upper endoscopy i did a
colonoscopy two weeks later and
essentially it was not so concerning I
mean she had normal
histopathology and the pathologist
basically said this looks like irritable
bowel syndrome I provided reassurance I
continue to follow her I gave education
on irritable bowel syndrome management
and I told her that you should keep a
trigger diary and figure out what makes
the symptom what are the things going on
in your life that might make the
symptoms worse so what happened is that
the patient changed providers health
care systems she ended up going on a
different insurance plan and she came
back to me as a second opinion about a
year later and and she had the same
symptoms the repeat labs were
unremarkable but because she kept coming
back to me I performed an m RN program
which is a MRI study to look at the
small intestine and I didn't see
anything there either so already you can
see how the the story keeps on unfolding
it just keeps on going she is not
feeling well she keeps coming back
doctor what's going on and obviously
irritable bowel syndrome is what we saw
or because of the absence of any kind of
clinical signs irritable bowel syndrome
is what we are left with and I kept
saying this is 0 about any way around
this time is when stole calprotectin in
my mind became kind of a good test to
try and I sent off the stool
calprotectin and it came back 98
micrograms program and I was reviewed
the literature and lo and behold I found
that that this particular level was
actually concerning for an elevated
calprotectin not too high but it was
high enough for me to not ignore it and
the decision to proceed to proceed with
the repeat endoscopy was made but what
I'm trying to say is that
it's not always clear if you don't have
a good marker for inflammation to go to
endoscopy or not go to endoscopy and
that's an important decision the
literature says that the decision to
proceed with endoscopy is not always
clear particularly when classical signs
are not present such as anemia or
inflammatory blood markers or gross
hematochezia is blood in the stool
patients often present with these
nonspecific symptoms such as mouths
abdominal pain intermittent diarrhea
generalised malaise which is fatigue and
more than half of all patients who
undergo endoscopy or colonoscopy for non
gross blood and other nonspecific
symptoms are diagnosed with functional
conditions a particularly irritable
bowel syndrome in adults and children
and yet we have to think about carefully
whether or not to undergo an invasive
procedure so the Eco calprotectin when I
reviewed the literature was ninety-three
percent sensitive to ninety-six percent
sensitive for a real inflammatory bowel
disease problem and it was pretty
specific at ninety-two percent for
adults and seventy-six percent in
children so if you look at the Cal
protecting on at the time of diagnosis
for inflammatory bowel disease it's
actually very good this is a study by
Tibble at all in the premier journal
guts back in two thousand so literature
has been available for a long time but
it's not just now becoming standard of
care to think about calprotectin testing
prior to it a prior to the decision to
go to endoscopy so calprotectin was very
effective in this study at a cut-off of
50 microgram per gram at differentiating
inflammatory bowel disease so all the
levels that were high on the left column
there
ested true inflammatory bowel disease or
Crohn's disease and and the the scatter
dots that you see in the middle on was
where patients with irritable bowel
syndrome who did not have inflammatory
bowel disease and calprotectin I just
wanted to say could be elevated by other
infectious invasive processes such as
infectious shigella or salmonella it can
be elevated in certain parasites that
are invasive in certain cancers as well
but going back to my patient that I saw
this really was a difficult case and I'm
so glad calprotectin helped me to make
this decision because I could have kept
on denying the fact that the pain was
from an inflammatory process so although
initially hesitant we repeated the
endoscopy and colonoscopy and deep down
into the duodenum or deeper down into
the small intestine I find these ulcers
and when I looked at the histopathology
it was confirmatory for duodenal Crohn's
which is really tough to diagnose
sometimes so it was the calprotectin
that made me bite the bullet and say
okay I hate to do this but we got to
repeat that endoscopy and colonoscopy
she's on a biologic called infliximab or
remicade which is the trade name and
she's doing remarkably well she's
actually about to enter college and
she's actually thriving and really
living a normal life here and if you
don't know c-diff can occur in the
context of inflammatory bowel disease
and it means that it is a possibly a
worse type of inflammation going on
inside the intestines so this is how I
think about the decision tree to undergo
the colon
could be and trying to figure out when
calprotectin is helpful so a patient
comes in was suspected inflammatory
bowel disease or irritable bowel
syndrome I do the screening for fecal
calprotectin and I undergo the endoscopy
or if it's very low if the calprotectin
is very low I keep on following the
patient obviously the endoscopy will
allow me to start therapy for
inflammatory conditions such as
ulcerative colitis or Crohn's disease or
if it's negative I look at other reasons
for ongoing symptoms so I wanted to
share with you very briefly a
cost-effectiveness analysis looking at
this particular decision tree that i
just presented so using that same
clinical cascade I populated this this
cost-effectiveness model which looked at
suspected IBD patients so the patients
that don't have the diagnosis of IBD yet
and then I did the fecal calprotectin
test and all these probabilities are in
the literature and the second decision
tree over in the B column on the right
was to figure out whether it was cost
effective at a certain cutoff level so
when I think of a high calprotectin is
it over 50 micrograms per gram or is it
over a hundred micro gram program and
does it really matter if it's 96 or 98
and how would it impact clinical
decision making and health economics so
essentially what we found is that out of
a hundred patients who were screened for
inflammatory bowel disease versus
irritable bowel syndrome in adults
calprotectin saves about about four
hundred seventeen dollars per patient
but delayed the diagnosis in in about
two patients out of the 32 patients with
ultimately i ve in children fecal
calprotectin saved about $300 but delay
the diagnosis a little bit more in about
five out of the 61 pediatric patients
who ultimately went on to have IBD by
simply doing endoscopy without even
considering people calprotectin testing
it would cost an additional almost
nineteen thousand dollars in adults and
over six thousand dollars in children to
avoid one false negative result from
fecal calprotectin testing so the few
dollar amounts needed to do the fecal
calprotectin testing in a scenario where
the clinician is stuck between irritable
bowel syndrome or inflammatory bowel
disease it is very cost-effective to do
the fecal calprotectin testing we also
found that fecal calprotectin cut off of
a hundred micrograms program sorry that
should be microgram not milligram versus
the 50 microgram program to do to do the
50 micro gram for gram as the ideal cut
off it would cost an additional fifty
five dollars in adults and forty three
dollars in children but it yielded two
and a half patients or six patients in
in adults and children respectively so
ultimately at the end of the day in our
discussion we said that if your clinical
suspicion for inflammatory bowel disease
is substantially high 75 percent or more
then then direct endoscopy would win
without calprotectin screening but for
most of the patients that we see in our
clinic where it's not a hundred percent
sure whether or not to proceed with
endoscopy doing the fecal calprotectin
screening is highly cost-effective and
it only takes a little extra cost to
have the cutoff very stringent at less
than
at 50 micrograms per gram so this
basically changed the way I practiced
and I am here today because I really
think that this is a great test for my
patients arguably one of the most one of
the most chief complaint one of the most
common chief complaints among my patient
cohort would be abdominal pain or
disordered stooling or diarrhea and i
have now kind of used that 50 micro gram
for gram as my cut off and i am actually
realizing that this is something that
the patients like as well because they
need that objective marker they need to
know oh okay i my my inflammatory marker
in the stool is high so I understand why
my doctor needs to do the endoscopy and
colonoscopy for inflammatory bowel
disease patients who have the diagnosis
I set the benchmark at less than 150
micrograms per gram there is less
evidence behind that but evidence is
emerging I just want to say briefly that
the limitations of fecal calprotectin
testing is that it does take a while for
the Cal protectant to come back but I
know smart folks in industry it you know
are trying to have more point-of-care
testing there's higher variability in
the higher numbers of calprotectin so
basically a 500 vs. a 650 might not be
that different and definitely don't use
the calprotectin at the time of the
clean-out for any gastroenterologist
that may be on the call on the webinar
and first morning calprotectin testing
is best so what's new on the horizon I
wanted to talk briefly about the fact
that more and more in the IBD literature
there's evidence to say that tighter
inflammatory bowel disease control is
better what I mean by that is
endoscopic healing or histologic healing
which are available only through
endoscopy and colonoscopy so when I see
no evidence of inflammation on endoscopy
or on the slides that's better than only
calibrating my therapeutics based on
symptoms alone so where we are in our
practice is that you know it would not
be realistic to scope everybody with
inflammatory bowel disease all the time
or more frequently to get at this
endoscopic healing objective but it may
be more feasible to look at the stool
for biomarker testing so new coastal
healing is now synonymous with deep
remission and there's always argument
about what this definition means but we
know that again full and the scopic
evaluation showing no visible lesions is
a good target to have in inflammatory
bowel disease and the Europeans are are
ahead of the game when it comes to this
they definitely are targeting that type
control and not having any visible
ulcers as the therapeutic target of
choice on the reason is because right
there here in the asterisk where we
think that tighter Disease Control will
actually future disease modify so a
patient who has good control at the
mucosal level now will potentially have
better disease course later on in the
future and that is particularly
important for my pediatric or young
adult patients who obviously have a much
longer life span to live than a 50 year
old or a 60 year old who would be new
diagnosis at the time of at the time so
on so the landscape here is changing
so when I think about completely coastal
healing obviously I need to use more
drugs such as biologics and I just
wanted to kind of step back just for one
second and quickly talk about CRP CRP is
a theory active protein and it's in the
blood it's a marker of inflammation and
what this slide is showing is that it
does not correlate with whether or not
you have mucosal healing so CRP has been
used in the past as standard of care for
assessing whether or not a patient has
endoscopic healing or clinical remission
of inflammatory bowel disease and it is
certainly not reliable and does not
correlate with in das endoscopic
findings so when a patient was
clinically active with Crohn's disease
CD is Crohn's disease fifty-five percent
has CRP basically a coin flip less than
8 milligram per liter so there's really
no correlation of very little
correlation between CRP and histology
and this is a problem because this used
to be this is what a lot of clinical
gastroenterologists are relying on to
tailor therapies so before I end I want
to end on three slides and those three
slides kind of represent the construct
of how I monitor inflammatory bowel
disease using calprotectin okay so after
diagnosis I monitor calprotectin
serially longitudinally over time
because i know that calprotectin
predicts endoscopic activity so without
having to scope my patients I can
actually more confidently have an
assessment of what's going on at the
mucosal level so what this study showed
in the
inflammatory bowel disease journal in
2013 is that patients with ulcerative
colitis UC had high calprotectin levels
at the time of endoscopic high-end
disculpa captivity and whenever the
patient had no endoscopic activity
correlating with mucosal healing it also
showed that the calprotectin levels were
low so it was about 90% ninety to ninety
two percent in terms of accuracy for
detecting and discussing remission so we
were able to confidently say that
calprotectin predicts endoscopic
activity the second slide of the three
here is that calprotectin actually
predicts IVD relapse so in patients who
are monitored over time with
calprotectin if the calprotectin trends
are going up I know that this correlates
in a statistically significant way with
patients who would ultimately relapse
into disease flare so this particular
study showed that calprotectin over a 12
month span was very good at predicting
relapse or disease flare it's for the
sake of time I'll just go right to the
third slide here the third point about
calprotectin monitoring after diagnosis
of IBD is that calprotectin predicts
drug responsiveness so you can monitor
how your patients are doing with a
certain therapy based on calprotectin
measurements over time so this
particular study it's a great study to
refer back to this study used remicade
or infliximab and there was a good
statistical significance in that
calprotectin levels over time
decreased under hundred and and many
under 50 micrograms per gram at at 10
weeks when the patients responded to the
drug infliximab and patients who did not
respond continue to have persistent
elevations in calprotectin so those are
the take-home pearls for me in summary
um I have really changed my practice in
terms of using calprotectin as a
diagnostic marker of whether or not to
do endoscopy at the time of diagnosis
and then secondly i am using
calprotectin as a monitoring biomarker
for how a patient does over time thank
you for your attention I apologize if I
went over but I'm free for discussion
afterwards and any questions you all
night have
thank you dr. Park for your presentation
a reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Park will answer
as many questions as time permits and
first question is do you expect
utilization of calprotectin to increase
with the use of biologic therapy oh
absolutely so that's a great question in
fact we have just come back from the
american college of gastroenterology
conference in hawaii glad it was there
and that was a big topic of discussion
how do we monitor disease response or
non response in a non-invasive way when
the outcome measure has become
endoscopic healing but obviously you're
not going to scope be patients
repeatedly in the context of using very
expensive drugs like biologics and as
you know biologics are rapidly
increasing around the world especially
with the advent of biosimilars in in
asia and europe it anticipated to come
to the states in 2017 so absolutely I
think how protectin is going to increase
the use of calprotectin is going to
increase rapidly there's talks about
using calprotectin as a biomarker for
non IBD but you know things such as a
surgical recovery monitoring marker and
I absolutely think it's going to
increase in use how will calprotectin
diagnosis be more useful than an AFC a
diagnosis oh and ask
right so right so so that's that's an
interesting question so a Nazca is a is
a is really an ask a positive test is
really for a prognostic indicator so a
patient who has asked a positive
antibody is someone who might have a
predisposition for a crohn's disease for
example if someone has p Anka positive
they have a predisposition to all sort
of colitis if they have a fever positive
or or some of the other markers and in
the blood that would suggest a certain
phenotype of Crohn's disease such as the
perianal disease or the or the
structuring sister lysing type so aska
and the calpro are on two different
levels askah and Anka p NK those kind of
markers are for guide for prognostic
indicators so that once the diagnosis is
made histopathologically you can tailor
therapy based on knowledge of what that
patient will phenotypically present on
going and then calpro as I have
discussed is a marker of new coastal
level inflammation and can be useful for
diagnosis and monitoring its
calprotectin better than the traditional
exam for fecal leukocytes yeah that's a
great question as well so equal
leukocytes and otherwise among the
clinicians known as equal white cells
sequel whites we just want a fecal white
and we just say
so I just want to clarify that sequel
white cells are dependent on the reading
of the slide it it's also limited by how
the staining process is is done so it's
more laborious less standardized and
it's not quantified meaning you can get
its quantified in a sense that you can
get you know greater than 15 greater
than 20 but again someone has to read
the slide speak of white cells I can can
actually represent inflammation as well
but i don't couple of limitations other
than just the preparation and in reading
of the slide you have to figure out
whether Oh fecal white cell of plus two
does that mean anything to me and what
is the cutoff because if I if I you know
swallowed if I had sinusitis and
swallowed you know mucus my sequel white
cells could be elevated So Cal Pro is
top protectin is more standardized it's
it's it's easier to test and
reproducible I I would think that the
inter inter variability would be less
with the calprotectin inter patient
variability and the inter technician
reading calpro because it's really
dependent on the machine would be less
than say the variability of the people
white cells long-winded answer but I
hope that gets at it but no one has
really compared head to head but I know
for a fact that when I spoke to a
different group of gastroenterologist
they were
had the same question and interestingly
we came to the conclusion that Cal Pro
was seemed to be much more useful Thanks
is there any benefits ordering fecal
calprotectin and lactoferrin test that's
a great question as well so I at my
institution we used to do boats now
we've actually just kind of gone over to
sequel calprotectin for a few reasons
you can quantify sequel lactoferrin but
our institution was just reporting it as
positive or negative as a binary result
so we found that less useful we like the
quantification of the of the sequel
calprotectin and as you know the
cut-offs were very helpful for us and
I'm actually writing now a systematic
review on fecal biomarkers and looking
through the literature as a whole fecal
calprotectin has much more strength of
evidence in use and and randomized
clinical trials are using fecal
calprotectin so I think that's what
we're going to start using okay if we
are going to start processing cow
protection which cut off would you
recommend for diagnosis how did you
establish the cutoff yeah so i would i
would highly recommend reading the paper
by van reenen lvan rhd en aan I believe
van Reenen at all and he did a
systematic review meta-analysis of the
various studies out there he some he's
it was written in the British Medical
Journal he's an expert in fecal
calprotectin along with biomarkers and
it shows there that a cut-off of 50 less
than
it was quite diagnostic over ninety
percent for inflammatory bowel disease
ninety-five percent so we have kind of
used van rheenen van rheenen paper we
also recently found a great paper by
Henderson at all in the american journal
of gastroenterology another systematic
review and meta-analysis and these two
papers agree very much that the
diagnostic cutoff is less than or equal
to 50 micrograms per gram and above that
should consider going on to an
endoscopic evaluation using those two
papers and the strength of evidence
there that's where we did our
cost-effectiveness analysis as I
presented earlier in the journal
clinical gastroenterology american
journal of gastroenterology clinical
journal and the 50 was used as a cut-off
for diagnostic purposes and then for
monitoring purposes the debate is still
in the air studies are ongoing but less
than or equal to 200 have been thrown
around less than or equal to 1 50 has
been thrown around but most likely it's
going to be somewhere in that range for
monitoring IBD afterwards it looks like
we have time for one more question and
it is do you routinely request
calprotectin testing for patients
presenting with stomach issues
absolutely um so looking at my schedule
for this afternoon and then tomorrow in
urgent gastroenterology clinic out of
the 15 patients that scheduled I just
looked at it this morning about seven
have a quote unquote abdominal pain as
their chief complaint so whenever you
have a vague complaint such as abdominal
pain
because it could be anything from
inflammatory irritable bowel post
infectious diarrhea many different
things can cause abdominal pain I want
to know very quickly whether or not to
go along that decision tree that I
presented of doing an endoscopic
evaluation and if I'm going to do that
and I want to know whether the pretest
probability is high that I will find
something so absolutely i will order a
calprotectin on probably all seven of
those patients I would like to once
again thank dr. Park for his
presentation do you have any final
comments dr. Park so I think you know
the area of monitoring inflammatory
bowel disease is rapidly evolving we
know from a from a clinical perspective
that less than 50 is a great cut off but
we will see many more longitudinal
studies prospective studies on what the
cutoff should be for endoscopic healing
and histologic absence of disease when
calprotectin is under a certain cutoff I
have a feeling it's going to be around
150 thank you I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would also like to thank
our sponsor in over Diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through May 3 2016 lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time bye